critics and audiences agree that Aquaman
feels like a breath of fresh air after
drowning in DC's mercury our efforts
it's a light funny adventure film
anchored by two charming leads and
bullied by eye-popping visuals but a
vessel this large can only turn its
rudder so fast and it's bound to have a
few barnacles still clinging to its hull
prepare for spoilers and continue
full-speed ahead to the three best and
three worst things about Aquaman Batman
and Superman have some pretty iconic bad
guys always giving them grief that
contrasts Aquaman doesn't the movie
introduces perhaps the two most
significant villains from the pages of
Aquaman Comics Black Manta and ocean
master both of them are okay but the
story suffers slightly from having two
separate antagonists diluting the story
central conflict it's a problem all to
comment to superhero movies at least we
know we'll get more of Black Manta and
that big laser shooting helmet of his
and the inevitable sequel Jason Momoa
was a highlight of Justice League and
fans have been looking forward to more
of his likable dirtbag embodiment of
Arthur curry not only does the Aquaman
solo movie live up to its potential as a
Momoa vehicle it supports him with one
of the best casts yet assemble for the
DC EU it's an eclectic ensemble with
some surprising cameos but each gets a
moment to shine and unlike some of the
more convoluted comic movies in recent
memory everyone's clearly on the same
page about what kind of strange
adventure they're on Momoa continues his
shtick as the buff waterlogged Firefly
with a heart of gold but being the
center of attention allows him to add
new layers to the character he lets
Arthur self-doubt bubble to the surface
in his most vulnerable moments making
him endearing without sacrificing any of
his rowdy charm meanwhile Amber Heard
successfully leads alongside him as
meera with a perfect balance of fearsome
focus and wide-eyed wonder from her seen
wandering Sicily with Arthur to her
battle through the city Hurd makes mera
a true standout Justice League formally
introduced audiences to Aquaman but only
had time for a brief exploration of his
Atlantean origins mera
appeared in one sequence in which Arthur
attempted to protect a mother box from
Steppenwolf Arthur expressed bitterness
over being abandoned by his mother Queen
atlanna
and he'll turn neglect against the
people of Atlantis the Arthur we catch
up with an Aquaman is less angry at his
mother he's aware that she was forced to
return to the sea and learns that she
was sacrificed to a monster filled place
got the trench for the crime of having a
half-breed son filling him with grief
and guilt the movie more or less has to
undo the motivations established in
Justice League in order to get his
character arc moving in the right
direction there's also a change in how
Atlanteans communicate it seemed in
justice league that Arthur Amira could
only talk inside an air bubble but
Aquaman has its characters speak freely
even when submerged it makes sense that
a movie set mostly underwater would
choose not to complicate its characters
ability to talk to each other in this
way but it raises the question of why
Justice League introduced such a clunky
conceit in the first place
fans might be slightly annoyed at
Aquaman's contradictions of established
DC EU lore but this actually becomes one
of its strongest assets the movie is
completely unburdened by connections to
other movies either past or present
where Batman vs Superman dawn of Justice
nearly drowned in setups and
introductions designed to pay off in
future installments Aquaman floats free
unencumbered by the sort of franchise
minded filmmaking that has sunk other
comic-book movies
aside from briefly mentioning Arthur's
battle with Steppenwolf Aquaman contains
no reference to any other DC characters
not involved in its hero's journey no
secret Lex Corp files no foreshadowing
of cataclysmic events to come it's just
a straight ahead adventure story about
Aquaman and his friends and enemies it
is in fact a perfect jumping on point
for newcomers to the DC Universe
something Warner Brothers sorely needs
after the convoluted webs of its
predecessors proved off-putting for
audiences and critics regardless of how
well Aquaman plays to its strengths it's
still going to be the story of a
would-be king who talks to fish and does
battle with merpeople it will probably
never reach the universal acclaim of
something like The Dark Knight a movie
based on comic books and treated as a
hard-hitting police drama
Arthur Curry's adventures will simply
never have the same potential for
crossover appeal but here's the thing
about a movie that leans all the way
into its own comic book silliness it's
exactly what DC films needs right now
while some discerning theater goers
might be turned off by such a goofy
outing as Aquaman it serves as the
perfect antidote to the grim self
seriousness of movies like Batman vs
Superman tell me
we've watched Superman die and we've
seen Batman live long enough to become
the villain even Wonder Woman solo story
didn't have much time for levity once
Diana arrived in the trenches of World
War one
Justice League had a jarring tonal
dissonance trapped somewhere between
brooding and romping pitchfork
but Aquaman is bright wacky and seems
intent on doing nothing beyond shooting
fun straight into viewers eyeballs
Arthur's tale is a feel-good story
concerned not with societal ethics or
the meaning of existence but with his
own journey to find his own place and
commit to what he cares about it will
never make a short list of important
films or warrant major oscar
consideration but it isn't trying to
it's just fun and in a year when Marvel
slaughtered half of all life in the
universe that makes it a welcome dash of
lightness and joy sure I just peed on it
[Music]